all right kevin hey how are you doing
good welcome back nice to meet you it's
been it's been a while six
eight months something like that i think
i think so so what's been going on last
time i said you you horrified us with
the
with your arm yeah it was uh it
was how's your arm today it's doing a
hell of a lot better you want to show me
sure before i get to it yeah it was an
ulcer
and ulcers take quite a while to heal
but if you guys know and y'all seen the
last one i looked before y'all can
absolutely see that
this thing has been doing a whole lot
better
oh it's closing up it's closed up now
it's now just a little scab
i should have wrapped it but i keep that
i kept it open for you guys to see
that um i ain't been tampering with it
it's over with using antibiotics or
anything like that um i was using
antibiotics
i'm going to get back on the antibiotics
just because um
doctors told me it was an ulcer and that
it's going to take a while to heal
but i've seen so many terrible wounds
like yours heal down here without
antibiotics
because i think the immune systems on
skid row are just so incredible
that no no no one's getting coveted no
one's no one's dying from these
infections they're all healing up just
fine
i actually think that being down here
actually will strengthen your immune
system
absolutely and um i absolutely think
that maybe
sixty percent of people have actually
had covet and didn't even know it
i do you know anybody who's sick i had a
lot of people in my family who had
called nobody on the street
on a sit on the streets wise no i
haven't yet i've not
i've talked to probably a thousand
people no no one knows anyone who's been
who have been sick but they have they
also have never gotten
checked that's true
they probably thought they had an
ordinary code and not knowing that
that was coping that's right and they
beat it but that's because the immune
system is since i've been coming down
here for a year and a half regularly
i haven't been sick once never been sick
once that once
yeah so um so last time you were here
you were
it was heroin that you were using it was
a hair one you you had a beautiful talk
on on
what it was like to use heroin but uh
what's going on now
i stopped here around not too long after
that video man um
it was through through the supporters
man
through the comments the people that
made comments on your video yeah
i didn't know how much love i had out
there and support
and and uh it was a hard battle
but i kept reading and reading and
doing research and and i eventually got
get away from that area you get away
from that area you get away from the
people you find new folks and
and uh you do new things
and you figure out what you did before
that life and you find that and you and
you and you search for that when you
find that that's that's what you you you
that's what you go for and eventually
you'll you'll you'll do you'll defeat
the
you'll defeat the the the
the the demon of the the heroine you're
defeated
by for number one
you have a physical uh dependence that's
the hardest part
that's the part that keep people running
back too heroin
so um so have you replaced it with
something else you can replace it with
a medical substance which is still a
drug
which is a methadone supple subutex
suboxone
you can self-medicate by bind off the
street also but
or you can kick a cold turkey and a lot
of people
can't call turkey by going to jail
and but how i did it was um i used a
little bit of medical help
i took methadone but i didn't i knew
that nothing dumb was a whole another
drug that i would have to
fight a whole nother battle will have to
fight after i'd
fight heroin with that so what i did was
i just wanted to beat the physical part
of the um
the left i mean the physical part of the
heroin so i said i'll use the methadone
just until i can heal from the physical
part because that's the only thing i
feel like i can um
i can win if i can just get that part
over with
and start using it for about five days
are you using something else
um no not not at the moment
um
how can i say i started methadone
five days got off of that i was i wasn't
having any physical withdrawals
so i started to figure out things
that i was doing before the heron
to get my mind focus on something else
because you have a mental dependence
also
and the mental dependence just that's
all you would think about all day is
that's all that you you think you ever
what did was that so
now the mental part is just as hard as
the physical part and i didn't know that
so um i started to think what am i good
at
i'm good at cutting hair look at that
music
so i started getting back into those
things and uh
that helped me get my mind off of you
know
the mental part but um that would still
always be there
you'll never forget the
the the the things that heroin had on
you you never forget the
the rush you'll never forget to hide
you'll never forget
anything that that that kept you on it
but you you never also forget how it
[ __ ] your life up either
creativity can be a great way to
change direction yeah um
but i had a loss in my life
i lost something that was dearly close
to me um
he's my cousin my first cousin but we
grew up
same house so we called each other
brothers and um
his name lorenzo hall
and you know that's my world that's my
that's my heart
um
that's something i i i i ain't never had
i never endured
that pain i still going through this
pain i
i don't think it ever healed this that
this pain this loss that i took in
i i i wish i wish it upon no one but i
know we all have to go through it and
i know that some people have worser
worser tragics than me but this is my
tragic and
i handled it the wrong way i
self-medicated again
on a drug that is um
opiate they call it fentanyl
um it's a recent thing
i've been smoking it it's a very
dangerous drug
and i i i know that i'm i shouldn't [ __ ]
around with this
so um that's why i'm here today to let
you guys know
that i kind of [ __ ] up a little bit
and i need your help
y'all support and um
why it's early in the early stages of it
i get the hell off of that [ __ ] too i'll
kick hair around the ass i kick this ass
too
yeah fentanyl is more dangerous than
heroin yes it is
but i am not using needles anymore and i
will never use
needles again but i am
still self-medicating because of the
loss and i don't want to
use that as an excuse but when they say
a pain killer heals pain it heals all
pain
you know how did your cousin die he got
shot
he got shot and uh
you know you think that you think that
something i could i've always felt like
something i could have done
is something i could have did or if i if
i was there
for what i could have did what what
little
i could have did to help him out
if he was with me that day
he you know any like i just i just
figured out some kind of way to blame
myself
for his loss but you know we all grown
we all make our choices we make our
decisions you know
he chose that life but i don't i didn't
give a [ __ ]
that's my that's my brother you know and
i'll give my life for him and i still
will
um but i can't bring him back you know
i can't bring him back he gone they they
took him away from me
he's gone and um
he don't you don't want me doing this
[ __ ] so no he wouldn't
so i got it i got to make it right for
him i got to wreck it right for my
family
i got my my father i got my mother my
sister my brother
they all got my back they never turned
they back on me
um i love them the most they
my best supporters and um
that's great that your family hasn't
turned their back on you and i got to
make it right for them man
they always say do it for yourself i i
definitely am doing it for myself
but damn it i got to do it for them too
if that's that's my god if i die i got a
guy trying
i'm going to do it for them i'm going to
do it for them
i love them and this is what they want
i'm going to give them what they want
they want their son back they're going
to have their son back slowly but surely
i just want them to know it take a
little time but
i'm i'm getting there you know i'm
getting there i'll be there
i i couldn't really tell y'all like i
want to tell y'all but
i'm coming home you know i'll be home
and y'all have me back kevin what do you
think the most
misunderstood thing is about drug
addiction i mean
you kind of you say you kicked heroin
and that's that's an incredible thing to
to to do but what i mean you've been
through you've been through hell and
back what do you think
people don't understand so people who
don't play around with drugs
what they don't understand is uh
the mind altered of a person who does
play around with drugs
um i see so many comments people saying
what a stupid decision you know you
should you should just stop
yeah it's just not that easy i mean it
probably did start off as a party thing
to do
and you know some people some people
minds are weaker than others
you know some people had that follower
in my time to see also
that's a weak mind and a strong mind
saying we're talking about the weight
line that the weight line is normally a
follower mine
and and that's what's called a
dependency now y'all both have
dependency on that drug
then um that's what the mind does it
makes you depend on the drug you
won't be able to do [ __ ] without it you
can't enjoy life without it and that's
where
this messes with your your depression
and yeah
it it blocks everything out all you want
is to get high
and it's not really getting highs i call
it self-medicating now
it's called getting well it's called
getting fixed
because without it you are not
well you you're sick literally like
who wants i mean you guys all have we
all had a flu before
think about having a flu
that's what it's like being dope sick
having a flu but 20 times it's worse
you uh some people even [ __ ] on yourself
man
um and
you don't want to you know that the only
thing you know to stop that is
to get what we call the fix and
uh that's that's what keep people going
the drug is
just to stay well how do you think uh
this has changed you what you just went
through because i know
your time addicted to heroin then off it
and now you're using fentanyl i mean
you certainly must have learned to
change in some way because i
took my mind i can say wasn't it wasn't
all the way
better it wasn't it wasn't strengthened
enough and then i had a lot lost in my
life
that i used that as an excuse
that's why i apologize to my to my
brother
to you have used him as the excuse to
try to alter my drug a drug addiction
with another drug um
but what but i do have a strength in
mind to know that
i'm wrong and i'm feeling that i need to
do something about that before this get
out of hand
and that's why i came back to you
to uh because on my first interview
i did um i didn't know it'd go big like
that you know
and um i was kind of embarrassed about
it but
you know i read the comments i didn't
reply to them but i read them i'm going
to start
back replying to him but i read them man
and i had so much love out there and
i didn't know that man and i didn't let
so many people down i didn't know that
people even looked up to me you know
and uh when i figured that out and i've
seen that man i
i said man they won't care but
and i had to do something about it
and um so i i had that part of my mind
still
so as long as i still had that part of
my mind
i will be okay and i know that i can i
can defeat this battle 100 percent
and and and i'll be back in no time
that's great that you can
find a little motivation in the in the
youtube comments that's great
if you can beat heroin you can probably
be fentanyl especially if it's only been
how many days
it's it's been about two weeks
yeah so i i know i can it's
i still have that part of my mind that
that that does
know that that that i'm doing wrong how
did you shake heroin
um uh i started the methadone
i knew that that's also a dependency
it's a drug dependency
and but you have to be on that long
enough also
to to to uh
to uh you know grasp that addiction to
that drug
and you'll be dependent on that and you
will have to go through another medical
uh another medical
treatment just to get off of that thing
so i knew that uh
maybe field hazel methadone just to beat
the physical dependence of
uh heron i think i think i can i'll be
okay i won't be addicted to the method
don't
and then my physical dependency on the
herring to be over with
i won't be sick and i feel like if i
don't be sick
dope sick then i wouldn't need the dope
which is true
but the mental part is also is just as
bad
but i was able to fight that
i was able to fight that by finding
alternatives that i like in my life
you have to search for them though you
have to
write it down you have to you have to
figure it out man you have to push
heroin away you have to make you have to
make yourself hate that [ __ ] you
have to
hate it you got to want to kill it you
got to want it
you got to know it's [ __ ] everything
up in your life
and um you'll beat the mental part
but i wouldn't say beat the mental part
because i think that will always be
there
but i think you will be able to handle
it
and uh be able to block it
and and that's what happened with me
replacing it with
with something else creativity or yes a
new interest or something that's great
and your family is still you're still in
touch with your family and they're
supportive oh yeah
that's very supportive oh yeah
especially my father man
especially my father i love him
dearly i'm kevin junior a senior
and and i live up to my name you know i
love benny jr
i thought that i am him i'm a i'm his
shadow
you know man that's that's one thing i
i want to fix because
his name means something
you know is there anything that you any
goals you have any anything you'd like
to do with your life if you get clean
yeah it goes is uh
my own place for one on my own place
working on that i should be having that
shortly
um
you're still living on the street no no
no
no i'm back at home i'm back at home
there you are
and that was a choice of mine i didn't
have to
but i wanted to i wanted to um
you know i didn't want to be around my
folks i knew i knew how i was
you know i couldn't do that
around them so i couldn't let them see
that part of me
and that was embarrassing so i ran
away sh shame is a big part of
addiction isn't it very big problem
people underestimate i think how
powerful shame is it makes you reuse it
makes you relapse it makes you makes you
do all
all the above and keep the cycle alive
and then some people wasn't as lucky as
i was to still have supporters
because you can lose everything man you
lose
you lose everything you got a wife a
girlfriend she's out of there
you know she's gone that's number one
and that has sent somebody further down
their addiction
and then you know you eventually lose
your family
and then eventually you look up you
ain't got nobody but the drug and the
[ __ ] around you
who do the drug and now how you gonna
get off of it
you know ain't got no way off of it
so the main thing is i have some
supporters man
someone who cares someone especially
somebody who has been there and who
knows
what it's like and that's normally a
sponsor
you know i recommend a sponsor but um
i don't have a sponsor but i i recommend
i do get a sponsor
we have a few thousand commenters you
guys
monsters you out and yeah and i will be
replying back to a lot of the comments
because you guys are the reason why i am
trying
trying i am trying awesome
well kevin i wish you the best of luck
thank you sir and uh i hope you
kicked this fentanyl yeah i thank you
that'd be great to
get get your life back together yes it
will you know
i hope i'll have further more stories to
come you have so much potential
thank you sir man thanks for coming back
it will do
you guys have a blessed
you